did he know the condom is over 5,000
years old that's right some of the first
forms of birth control date back to
around 3000 BC and while the condom has
made some strides since the Bronze Age
men still don't have a much better
option all these millennia later besides
a vasectomy especially compared to the
pills
IUDs and implants available to women
today so why don't we have birth control
for men in 2002 researchers asked more
than 9,000 men across four continents
whether they'd be willing to use
contraception capable of preventing
sperm production over half said yes so
the problem isn't lack of interest it's
partly human biology women ovulate just
one or two eggs each month men on the
other hand produce sperm daily and it's
not just one or two there's literally
hundreds of millions of sperm produced
each day so because there's so many
sperm produced actually you can reduce
your sperm number over 90% and still be
completely fertile to reach infertility
a man's sperm count needs to be
somewhere around one to ten million per
milliliter but getting there is near
impossible at least without side effects
that's because sperm count is tied to
the production of testosterone in the
past researchers tried decreasing
testosterone in an effort to decrease
sperm count the problem is you don't
have any libido you have very little
testosterone to act on other tissues and
so forth and so the side effects were so
dramatic that it really wasn't ever
going to be a contraceptive pill
scientists also tried using different
compounds to attack the cells that
produce sperm but again biology got in
the way germ cells as they're called
developed inside a fortress-like
structure within the testes so literally
nothing can get through it there's been
a lot of small molecule studies to try
to actually attack the germ cell to stop
it from working literally I can think of
10 or 15 different compounds
actually have been developed to do that
but they don't work because of that
barrier but the complex male anatomy
isn't the only problem it's also funding
or lack thereof in 2002 two big
pharmaceutical companies took interests
in male contraception shearing and
organon and together they funded a large
clinical trial on a hormone based
contraceptive offering hope that a pill
backed by big pharma might be on the
horizon then these two companies became
as you know acquired by bigger company
and an even bigger company so now they
emerge in huge companies and women's
health is still a priority in many of
the companies but men's health became
part of the general medical health and
therefore the development of
contraception becomes a really very low
poverty according to dr. Wang male
contraception was also too risky for Big
Pharma at the time the long term side
effects were unknown companies were
concerned that women might not trust it
and despite the survey results it was
unclear whether men would actually use a
hormone based contraception today the
limited funding comes mostly from
government agencies like the National
Institutes of Health but there are in
fact some promising lines of research
dr. Wang is working on a gel that can
lower testosterone where it matters in
the testes where sperm is produced while
keeping testosterone levels normal
elsewhere that means low sperm count and
more importantly no major side effects
we have preliminary studies to show that
if we give the gel and if the man
applies a gel 90 percent of their men
will reach the level that you talk about
1 million camille and scare is pursuing
a new approach shutting down sertoli
cells which are a part of that
impenetrable barrier that houses germ
cells so if you shut down this 2 totally
so then you shut down the sperm
production but perhaps most promising is
a sort of reversible vasectomy that's in
the work
so they haven't ability to inject this
gel into the what's what's called the
vas deferens and it makes this plug so
then in a sensor it does the same thing
but you're not cutting it and believe it
or not you can actually inject this
chemical mixture which will dissolve the
plug and so then you can get your
fertility back but as promising as these
approaches maybe there's still years if
not decades out Skinner says and without
more funding some of them may never hit
the market so at least for now men are
left with few options irreversible
vasectomies pulling out if done
correctly and that slightly updated
Bronze Age invention